joining me now by phone eric trump with
the latest on his dad's condition
good evening eric hey good evening judge
thanks so much for being with us tonight
um i know
obviously it's your dad you love him
it's highly personal but what can you
tell us about how your dad is doing
and uh i understand that you've spoken
with him today
at length talk to us yeah no i did and
at least anytime you see your father go
to the hospital you know he's the man i
i love i respect
um he's an absolute warrior i mean i
think everybody in this country has seen
that he is an absolute warrior every
single day
whether it's whether it's this or
anything else he gets up and he fights
um every single day and he fights
ferociously no matter what it is he
fights you know incredibly hard for the
american people and
um you know obviously covet is is very
very serious um obviously something
that's affected a lot of people
um and obviously something that hit him
um you know very hard in the
opening days but i probably spent 20 25
minutes on the phone with him today and
he sounded uh
he found it incredible honestly he
sounded clear he sounded great
um the entire time he was actually
talking about uh the new aid package he
was talking about
mitch mcconnell and stimulus and he
actually
mentioned the airline workers um and and
things that he wanted to do to them and
i mean
the man just never takes his foot off
the gas he just never
ever lets up he might be in walter reed
but i can i can assure you he was
he was running a thousand miles a minute
and and that's the person i think most
americans
come to see and the guy is absolutely
incredible he's the energizer bunny
um nothing takes him down and as serious
as as covet is and as scary as it is for
me as a stunter to to kind of watch the
whole thing i mean
i don't think ever watching marine one
take off on the white house lawn to go
over to walter reed is
uh is something i want to uh you know
it's it's uh probably a memory i won't
forget
but um the man is just remarkable i mean
he is an absolute warrior
i love him to death he sounds great he
was full of energy and um
i think it's going to be a quick
recovery and then he's going to get back
to it he's going to start fighting again
and we're all going to fight and we're
going to keep winning for america and
and we're going to win on november 3rd
eric i want you to take a listen to this
sound and i want to get your reaction to
it on the other side
so i just want to tell you that i'm
starting to feel
good uh you don't know over the next
period of a few days i guess that's the
real test so we'll
be seeing what happens over those next
next couple of days
you know eric i mean it is your dad and
and to hear him say that
you know you don't know what's going to
happen in the next couple of days
how does that make you feel well i
listen it doesn't it doesn't make you
feel um great at the same time i mean i
heard the energy and i heard the
figure in his voice tonight and um i
mean he was again
um you know incredible as i said before
and so you know this is deadly virus
it's something that you have to take
credibly seriously and
he was the first person to shut down you
know travel to china by the way i think
my father's going to hold china fully
accountable because they need to be held
accountable but
you know that's for a later date but i
mean he's the first guy that you know
you know shut down
travel what they've done with the
vaccines and therapeutics is
unbelievable
no one could have done it faster than he
did what they did creating ventilators
and other things
no one could have done it faster and now
he's battling something that's affected
so many americans there's so many people
around the world to tell you the truth
and um
he's going to beat it and we're going to
beat the virus and we're going to
continue fixing this country and
you know judge the last thing i mean you
know i see videos all day on fox you
know of these incredible supporters
outside walter reed they're holding
american flags and they're holding
to make america great flags and it it's
just the
outcry of support for him is incredible
i mean we live in a nation that
absolutely loves him you see that the
rallies where they're literally chanting
we love you
you know a couple years ago was build a
wall it was this and that it was you
know a lot of red meat stuff
now you're chanting you know we love you
this nation loves him he's done a great
job for this country and as a son i just
could not be more proud of the man and
um
he's going to get past this and he's
going to get healthy and we're going to
go out there we're going to fight
we're going to keep winning for this for
this great nation that we all love so
much
you know a couple of things eric you
know when you when we saw him today in
that
video that that that uh he put out this
afternoon you know
i think everyone kind of had the sense
that if he was in walter reed you know
it's
it's a hospital and he's probably going
to be in a row but no there he is in the
navy suit and his shirt
and he's got his hair combed he looks
great uh
and and it is it's got to be reassuring
to
uh you know you not only but to him as
well
because he takes those incoming every
day
but to have the opportunity to hear
people outside of walter reed
you know honking their horns yelling
telling him they love him
i mean i see it when i go around the
country but you know it's a wonderful
thing
for him to at least be able to take in
the love and the prayers
that people have for him and hopefully
um you know this is something that you
know he can carry with him
to kind of fight off the hate that comes
from the left that i'll talk about in a
few minutes on the show
but any last thoughts eric no listen
there's tremendous hate from the left uh
there's tremendously
even in a time like this which should be
a somber moment for everybody and
there's also been tremendous love
you know i can say you know more so than
i've seen a long time there's also been
absolutely tremendous love but
you know he's done a great job for this
nation he sacrificed so much for this
nation he wakes up
every single day and he goes to war for
this nation uh personally there's
probably never been a
you know president that sacrificed more
than he has and um and i again i
couldn't be more proud of him the guy's
uh
and inspiration to me as the son and uh
and to so many others and uh he's gonna
get through this and uh everybody's
praying for him and he sounds great and
um
and uh again he's gonna keep making
america great that's exactly what all of
us want
you know somebody that stands up for red
white and blue and never apologizes for
america
keeps working on behalf of this country
which he does so well
now eric trump thank you so much for
being with us tonight and thanks for
sharing
thank you